[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like the herbs to light beer
[Music]
tippy tops
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what
[Music]
the bomb
you are a lewd terrible person bombs
the bomb
do you realize what you've said I should
do it's pounded in my brain awful enough
for sleep and awaken in the drowsy
fantasy moment of every known leader
[Music]
if I tell my mom
and she tells you
if I tell mine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now I can say is lived until he's loved
or God loved someone I do her you tell
me no you know me I'm home to ship I'm
if I could cable her why not semaphore I
feel you've gotta declare self openly
alibis y'all stay right where you are
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why were plain simple ma'am I have
played some feelings and I use plain
simple words and I simply have to let
you go
lately the ice namely i'm pimply what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rather than you having oh no really I
thought you ought to give him a chance
he seems kind of helplessness is the
last thing I am looking
[Music]
even sanity
[Music]
even Sammy
[Music]
please if we're going to spend the rest
of our lives together you must learn not
to interrupt mr. panner
[Music]
[Music]
it's June and louder with Crowder is
concluding our fourth annual cultural
appropriation month only instead of
travelling to some third world at whole
this week we're covering the only
culture that matters America so drink a
beer call ice in one of your co-workers
and wrapped yourself in the only flag
that counts join us as we make cultural
appropriation months great again because
to appropriate is to appreciate
hey the string everybody before we have
replacement is wrapping up that means
United States Pledge of Allegiance
everyone please stands one nation
because there are so many flags
hopefully you don't throw the sign of
disrespect it's all true look at all the
flags
you can't not look at a flag in this
area
we literally have 11 t5 Flags that's I
don't even know rhadigan hasn't already
gotten into the gym it's all really
quickly guys everyone use the hashtag
debate Crowder debate stream tonight
we're gonna get into our thoughts and
prayers here in a couple of seconds I
guess now we have Dave Rubin John
Stossel many celebrity cameos want to
let you know we have a costume contest
for cultural procreation on wrapping up
best costume we'll be reading them aloud
quarterblack Garrett later and also send
us in that you still have time for the
submissions you're not too late the most
American thing you could think of stand
in a video and we'll be running the best
ones later today we'll see the trivia
before the break drinking game rules for
tonight before we get to the debates all
right let me make sure I have this right
this is gonna be let us know send us
your tweets you have to take a drink any
time the words fascist or ISM ashes
racist gay drink twice if it's but gig I
support Asian border crisis camps
migrant fair shares fairness white
supremacist Trump 1% student loans for
debt marginalize LGBTQ parentheses AAA
IP we must a Planned Parenthood
reproductive rights women's rights
Medicare for all drink of Tristram
Gillibrand yes Marlon question Obama
Maliki gun-control yang gang
millionaires billionaires Wall Street
and you know what we'll come and make
some real that is the Jordan run out of
beer that's something we should drink
for and let's send in the the lovely
American ladies to get a set up we have
a keg tonight we do Sam Adams because
that's the only large-scale brewery that
I know that supports yes
except for Yuling but we all agree that
sucks alright so tonight we have we are
down to 42 people I believe yeah 42 what
do you guys expect before we get to the
debates here uh you know what given that
last night they were talking about the
the candidates speaking in Spanish I'm
looking for like that kind of moment
again they weren't talking about they
were speak no I know but that's what
everybody talked about afterwards right
so that was the thing that people were
just most up in arms about and thinking
was hilarious I'm looking for somebody
to go no I can top that tonight like I'm
looking for the hold my beer moment like
Bernie Sanders you start speaking and
finish somebody's gonna do something
really stupid but they're gonna think
they're connecting with the American
people
yeah that's what I'm looking for and how
else want to be a Bernie Sanders to
start speaking the Swedish Chef just
came out in this podium shushing you
know what it is I mean the entire today
it has just been one giant like Burning
Man of [ __ ] I'd be shocked pretty
much it says live Brautigan by the way
we strongly expect that's why you're not
hearing the debate right now it's a
watch along so tune in your TV to debate
or on YouTube because our stream could
very likely be removed from so blaze
yeah you can watch this tonight for free
on blazed on blaze TV and the app also
by don't we just cross four million
subscribers Young Turks don't be but
there are Armenians who are not rolling
over in their graves no yes not at all
there actually was this music playing
[Applause]
thank you very much yes I just beer this
is all film it's very fun was that two
club which our thing last night we have
a saying and was administered it'd you
say we have a saying Minnesota was she
last night saying in Minnesota all foam
and no beer soda I mean at least go with
the head joke no she wasn't saying it
about Minnesota she was saying that she
said it in Minnesota
oh so other ways this is one of those
things they're going to be twelve
debates we've got to pace ourselves this
is the last show by the way of course at
the store we're gonna be on break up
until August first in the studio but we
are going to have master class with
David Barton up next week so we have
like five to ten videos that are going
up during this this little hiatus and
you haven't seen David Barton you really
do have to watch his stuff it's really
cool yeah it isn't when there is just
kind of turning into this stuff and you
haven't seen it yet
good good good stuff well here's the
thing I know it was a luck of the draw
right as far as the the candidates being
on the other night but what a crappy
drawing last Elizabeth Warren yeah and
everybody else yeah we weren't planning
at doing this both nights we were and
then we survived just worn a night run
that's it okay obviously we have we have
Michael is it Bennett you say so
we have Bennett we have Saul well mr.
swallows my dark my face and then
yesterday that I think I was it Ainsley
I always forget that guy I don't even
know how he is and we have Williamson
tonight as far as I please someone let
me know as far as it was she there she
wrote some kind of a book on pseudo
spirituality yeah and how many of you
feel do you thing or just trying to sell
book that thundering at this point well
I mean basically it's just for
popularity sake so you can do something
else and make money off of it outside
there's no way some of these people
pulling it 0.1% are gonna have any kind
of show that's the thing out of like you
know the 270 people running maybe five
actually winning the nomination there
are people like you know Booker and
kirsten gillibrand who I just I loathe
Oh show the things you think they're
special enough where they should win but
no one else likes them and then there's
everyone else who figures they can get a
job on like MSNBC
or write a book I mean name it Casey in
their name a candidate that doesn't have
like this huge Achilles heel like huge
Bernie he's he'll their jerk right no no
bad it was all bad again I would just
love it if right away they came out and
Bernie started speaking spit on ously
smart money bets its Biden right yeah
but I I think that dividin versus opa
bringing them out or they bringing them
out yeah oh I can't a little bit about
Rush's here with a balloon Joe Biden
look at yahng yahng yahng as little
fictitious lats pretty was like walking
out there like a like a Mexican boxer
know where that's high all right let's
bring up some of the volume area we're
gonna be really careful tonight because
we might get taken down so we can't show
it fullscreen oh I do like that he's not
wearing a tie though how are they out
there seven minutes before debate
tonight seven minutes yeah so yeah looks
pretty I gotta say no time you know I
believe that mauler
then a man named yang is nothing like
perpetuate in the original stereotype
but get bicycles shrinking into his suit
like Tom Hanks and big at the end I love
it walking down the street I can't leave
Arnie combed his hair
yes wall well guys want to do something
he dumbest or funniest thing tonight
I bet anything he's desperate it's like
a desperate fight [ __ ] suspect the
second to your people to come out and
just be like swing the Jews did not 11
you know during the Republican primary
when we had 150 candidates it was right
the debate was a matter of like what one
person is gonna break out cuz I like the
our very first debate it was Carly
Fiorina I had the really good
performance right she worked her way up
to the main stage right him you know he
has a stylist Bernie now look that's a
whole different look that's my makeover
someone says Bernie listen we're gonna
you know well shift to the direction la
party and this one thing I will say I
agree with Young Turks tell me how last
night you could see Bernie's
fingerprints all over the debate it is
true the party has gone so much further
to the left remember when they asked
Bernie they said what do you think the
most serious national security threat is
in the last election you said climate
change everyone laughed right yesterday
I was like me too me too
absolutely default which doesn't make it
like a sense because the Democrats are
in a position well at least with the
current president is not one of the
popular guys in a world where if you're
ever gonna like make a tag for the
middle to try and peel off the rock hard
in three states instead they're going
straight on to like the most bat poop
crazy right left decided I think you're
gonna do success because of people like
a OC so I don't think it's just Bernie I
think it's because he's got somebody
like a OC who really is just a dumpster
fire that people are watching again the
owner reason ALC is elected is because
she went
New York City a ham sandwich well we do
what you wanted to send it by the way
you're most the most American thing you
can think of and actually we we did it
we did it ourselves really as a matter
of fact I think do we have it we have it
live actually right now we go to one of
those American things we could think of
for cultural appropriation we have a
concentration camp oh oh oh we go now
live to our concentration camp in Scent
polish yes I'm sorry
and it was Obama who builds it these
shadows are what they are do not blame
me yes okay then that was obviously
someone who's been in the cage since
Obama put him there senator Obama
started it and he wants our help but I
put there it's called the economy
I feel great shame from HR just walked
in to take him down please don't tell me
we got here very awkwardly there's OHS
we are by the way tonight we have I bet
you they don't talk of course border
crisis climate change abortion economy
education election interference guns
health care immigration slave
reparations Universal childcare because
Flav reparations is mainstream now yes
well it is now this cameras they just
get the guy from the wire they're just
doing this whole this whole zoom in hand
it's the same guys who saw a coin was it
Bohemian Rhapsody I always want to say
Queen because it is going on now that
the cameras just going back and forth at
shot remember constantly constantly
moving around like I thought my wire
reference was better time to see this
was all foam yeah mines gone down yes I
have to paint myself because the
drinking game tonight it's always a lot
of fun of course we're not liable if you
uh do you uh not because we're not
bartend what happens if I puke on
electrical equipment that then can't
Slyke takes thank you use your beard at
your 503 you if you don't shut up all
right fair enough so I'm trying to think
it when we talk about how some of these
people are racing super far to the left
or quickly to the left
pick one person on that stage tonight
one person who you would say when they
talk about the current Democratic Party
and they try to say that they're a party
that's a wider tent one person they're
probably Biden who would have reasonable
points of view who'll be more of a
centrist maybe so I think maybe solo him
yang I don't know
yang but there's a lot of libertarians
out there that might feel like that's
not a bridge too far so I don't think
he's mainstream by anything yeah I think
he's more with the mains you know if I'd
have perked if I'd have rented you for
the evening for a look-alike I'd send
you back sir do you have any proof of
what he said you yang was moderate all
right you notice I look at him sir I'm
sorry that Turkey that won't be pardoned
I said he came on anything as I think I
think Hickenlooper and Bennett are
actual moderates but I don't know which
ones they can look okay hey bye thank
you so much sweetheart uh something I
find hilarious did you do that Pete so
Pete but cake you just saw a smaller
than yang stop it very holy man by the
way you don't say don't criticize him
for a sexuality queer says him for his
ideas okay let me ask you this everyone
here Pete but get his ideas are gay what
are his ideas what do you know about
Pete Buttkicker gun control how much you
want to guarantee talks about being a
gay man things gay yes he was a gay guy
in the military good for him but if you
think he's feminine you think he's small
which he is credit did you realize that
his husband took his name to his husband
Sigma there is a man out there who
ditched his maiden name to become mrs.
buck gig Hey well that's commitment
right there coin like how do you
determine that I'm this is a genuine
question for any gigs like sort of I
honestly don't know switch off everyone
snow proposes do they just whoever
thinks of it first
I have no be somebody takes that role
somebody's got to I guess no no you know
I feel like I don't know enough about
this guy you definitely don't know
enough I don't want to know if you send
me on a special report anywhere to find
out more I will be pissed off we're
gonna send you San Francisco to actually
monitor
okay I'll do it equal chair long as I
can drive right up the road in Le baby
we have one minute by the way this is
something what are you talking about
pure policy when we get to the debates
and that's gonna be wildly unfun but um
we should San Francisco San Francisco
not only ban jewel cigarettes but the
other way their home is San Francisco
and vaping products and nicotine not
only do they ban it for sale in San
Francisco they banned shipping really
nicotine products to San Francisco huh
where do they focus so you can you can
go in as a [ __ ] and take a dump on a
fake mustache and a little girl's room
right yeah walk out smoke a joint take a
crap on the street but the second you
grab a vaping product you're kicked out
of city lines
that's incredible the things they choose
to care about baffle me doesn't baffle
me at all
it makes perfect sense to me even if
people are being idiotic right
okay can we bring up the sound a little
bit their audio Wade just so we can see
I want to know when they start asking
the questions this is really awkward
than making them stand out there do you
think it's because of the fault last
night nice like backstage was a joke
induced Matthews taking a piss in his
back it's like what was it maked Gunn 33
2/3 or he's in the bed that was what
happened last night
oh that was what happened yeah the mics
kept going there we have to go to a
break go to a break go to a break
because I heard that was Mike's idea
like the other mics yeah it was wildly
embarrassing whatever and so if I have
to bet probably Biden I think I think
Bernie probably beats Donald Trump in a
general I hate to say it I think he's
the one who would have the most the
highest like that I'll explain to you
why in a second oh look Lester Holt
commonly known as what race is that guy
question mark man that is a little that
is a little I've got a lot of people
picture put a black Garrett they think
the picture in your wallet of your
father is Lester Holt the one that just
comes with the sock wallet I'm sorry dad
he's watching it yeah I know and Chuck
Todd Oh Chuck Todd looks like a family
of caterpillars just went right on it
with a beard and just laid a bunch of
eggs I know I know we don't want to
place too much emphasis on there being
presidential but if your headshot makes
you look like Ben Shapiro would kick the
crap out of you in a street fight
probably should switch so funny to me
this is
is what andrew yang when they took it
take a picture his picture an old flip
camera phone he's trying to send his
relatable Savin actually by the way and
really I'm gonna be on the show what are
you doing sometime here soon
is there something not going out with
the stream I see Tim from HR here fixing
some bait jars just doing alright okay
let's bring up the sound a little bit so
we can hear this let's go to the debates
who's first
send in most of hashtag Crowder debate
stream yes watch along because we have
to keep the volume kind of in and out
because we never know we're gonna be
removed it have cameras on them I will
say Lester Holt though always dresses
nicely he does have good food yes he's
got a good table many ruins it with
those Harry Potter glasses face Wow poor
gentleman listening why are you saying
if it's all gonna be ad hominem no it's
just nothing else has happened yet yes
we're waiting
honestly this is how it starts we're
just getting warmed up he looks like
Chuck Schumer had sex with a GI Joe
Williams that's a crazy woman that's the
face of a crazy woman that's the face of
it randomizes a little littles your pet
rabbit like I would expect before the
first question Shiva yo I swear somebody
swallows my candidate that's gonna speak
Spanish tonight
he's my guy all right let me hear I
can't hear that much I worked out like a
charm at night never works and they
don't say anything
Sanders care and free college in a
recent interview drinky calls from it oh
yeah it's right universal health the
middle class in a Sanders administration
and if so how do you sell that of course
they well they absolutely have to
let's here's answer we have a news Asian
for America by the way how's your vision
Bernie
country 2045 of America 500,000 people
are sleeping out on the streets today we
think it is time for change real change
no I don't know let me hear human right
and Human Rights either it is gosh human
right drink by the way he's not
answering the question you know except
she's not answering the question at all
the question was would middle-class
Americans see a tax raise under a
burning ministry here's a whole second
spoiler alert
yes the answer should be this of course
you filthy [ __ ] have you seen any of my
prior installments what I mean but
that's the dumb thing with these
glorified joint press conferences none
of them answer the questions because
they're talking to everyone at home
right will sweet drink
Walter G's billionaire by the way guys
this is a watch along so turn your TV to
the whatever stations yeah because watch
along on on one of the here we go she's
asking again in a Sanders administration
those are private services yes I
understand you answer there you go okay
and here by the way these that's really
important to know people say it's a tax
break for the wealthy okay we've talked
about this and I think we have this even
we can bring it up as an overlay at some
point here tonight when you look at
Americans and specifically you look at
the bottom 20% not only do they pay
nothing in taxes but when you look at
the federal transfers that they see they
pay net negative meaning federal
transfers welfare right public programs
foods and things like that that they get
they pay a net negative of 58% yeah all
the way up through the middle class
there's a net negative that they pay an
income tax caps then you have the top
20% pay 30% of them come in to taxes
47% of Americans pay no federal income
tax whatsoever so when people say this
is a tax break for the wit rich it is it
is necessarily a tax break for that
remaining half America who pay taxes and
don't have net federal transfers right
this is the big lie that they don't want
to tell you that's why Bernie Sanders
doesn't want to answer that question
every single person would have to pay
more
taxes you want to know how if someone
will pay more in taxes okay in the
middle class if they paid 1% they'd be
paying more in taxes yeah absolutely all
right they're asking Biden is even
saying something worth listening to that
you are part in your administration
destroys a tea kettle
hold on hold on you want to hear what
he's safe situation we do Donald Trump
has put us in a horrible situation 50
year unemployment low highest job
participation rate that we've seen in
decades we have more jobs and there are
people to fill them yes I know there's
one thing your to think right now
there's no doubt that economic
opportunity is better than ever before
it's the only way the only way that you
don't buy that is if you give in to envy
and say yeah but that's the eeo has more
rights this in fact the entire spectrum
of answers right now have just been
based on the seven deadly sins it's
gluttony envy yeah right lust I'm sure I
saw someone looking at Williamson
someone give Kevin Spacey with the
[Applause]
ladies - I I'm already out it's
frustrating by the way she's half Indian
people know really yeah that we change
the tax code second people who work the
most does anyone out there know right
now the average average work hours per
week for Americans whoa no 34 hours
that's the amount of time worked for the
average American worker right now I
haven't seen a 34 hour week since 2008
what is that that's a 34 hour work week
it literally Dumb and Dumber they were
mocking listen they're not they're not a
job in this town yeah
laughing today the average worker hours
that's insane by the way oh man that's a
rug that would give Frank Luntz a run
for would you say you approve hands up
disapproval approve disapprove promise
every American government job Bernie's
health care works for me universal
health care look at yang you look so
bored I don't know if that's just
resting Asian face where is half asian
lawyer bill when you need to really wait
I feel like they might have some facial
recognition lose this election because
he couldn't be bothered with white
strips it's back to Bernie already
really Trump is a pathological liar a
racist all the criticisms to lob at
Donald Trump racist is not one of them
it doesn't work now no one really buys
the whole racist data there's that one
story like 20 years ago in the hotel
come on what happened the hotels that
were he raped his wife no
oh come on well allegedly allegedly I'm
just saying like if you toss if I were a
Democrat I would toss that in there
I trust that in there you know they
don't someone lays a search there's
reasonable doubt right I wouldn't even
go into racist no one buys a catch of me
right exactly I'm Meghan McCain lost
weight is good second why is it greedy
right why is it greedy for someone who's
created jobs and earned wealth to keep
it but it's not ready for Bernie to take
it
Gillibrand says that when Bernie takes
it he's giving it to charity less than
3% multi-millionaire less than 3% to
charity exactly
Carly wrote off his underwear donation
to thinks he's a prick
yeah no I just can't wait for president
Kirsten and Vice President Stacy -
they're really they're just throwing out
all of these these these things without
any evidence they're saying these things
are bad and I can fix them by changing
the economy and relative question who's
that guy that's Bennet Oh
oh wait wait Trump Colorado he's
probably high I thought Hickenlooper was
Colorado senator Hickenlooper is
governor former governor this is that
one [ __ ]
that is [ __ ] here's this is one of
the biggest lies that you hear here to
say oh and they talked about this last
night
there hasn't been economic growth first
off there's more economic opportunity
today in America yes and there has been
in over half a century now what they try
to say is average earnings hasn't
haven't gone up no no what they use is a
use of metric average hourly earnings
okay and they say that hasn't gone up it
really hasn't gone up that much when
adjusted for inflation remained a pretty
constant but you know it has gone up
five percent year-over-year huh its
average individual income that the
important measurement in other words for
example everyone here right who's worked
at this company quarterblack Garrett
audio way too cute Maddy we have a
Columbia manager I want to ask about
Beto's Spanish and not too long right um
they move up within the company now if
you're a PA at the company that job is
still worth the same amount of course it
gets an increase because of inflation
that being said
people in this company make more money
flipping burgers at McDonald's is still
worth about the same amount it's exact
presents the same amount of value but
individuals consistently make more and
the reason there's a bigger between
average hourly earnings versus
individual income is it takes into
account how long you've been into a job
how young you are and the longer you
live the longer you've been at a company
you kind of hit this arc right and I
think we have this as an overlay to cute
mannequins can bring this up there's an
arc there's a chart that shows people
get huge raise that the middle portion
of their career they start off it stays
pretty stagnant yeah then they move up
and when they get older it remains
relatively stagnant because now they're
in the upper echelon of earnings this
idea that Americans do not earn more is
not true I want you to tweet me tweet me
at us Crowder uses the Crowder hashtag
Crowder debate stream and let me know if
you've worked in the same job for 10
years or more if you have not seen an
increase that's why I don't think this
is gonna work because people go to haunt
second I know that's not true
yeah and he's saying that that only 10
percent of Americans are really
benefiting from this economy are you
serious when unemployment goes down who
you think God employed on but gig yeah
that's your house to be able to
refinance your student what do you think
oh yeah Frank's very keen class families
to subsidize even the children of
billionaires negative of twenty to fifty
percent in taxes this is what's crazy to
me listen I understand that you don't
like billionaires I get it right they
have a lot of stuff people are jealous
you don't want billionaires you think
they're dicks understood but the fact is
an average lower middle class American
is being subsidized by the wealthy class
they are not subsidizing billionaires
they're receiving more federal transfers
than they are paying and income tax
forty-seven percent of Americans don't
pay federal income taxes that's what
killed Romney's campaign yeah never
everyone got furious with that he said
for some Americans don't pay for what
everyone should pay something yes how
about 2%
how about two anything guess what you've
seen entirely even voting block yes you
would for the same reason they don't
want there to be voter ID because they
know that they would see an entirely
voting bloc right no pops would be
bothered to make sure the people are
citizens on the census or to vote in the
night representative of the United
States the next powerful most powerful
leader of the
world for that same reason they don't
want people to pay taxes because if
people pay taxes guess what Democrats
never win again no ubi I think three
point two trillion dollars a year I like
him discos you the wrestling fans now we
need to put the American people in
position to benefit from all these
innovations and other parts of the
economy and if we had a value-added
taxes even half the European law oh god
here we that tells you we need people to
see benefits from innovation typically
innovation is a benefit in of itself
regional economies and neighborhoods
creating millions of jobs millions
here's a question right he says right oh
people are uh you know these are these
innovations are hurting people if we
give them a thousand dollars of spending
in their local economies or people will
take a thousand dollars think it's
better than anything they can spend it
on drugs they could spend it on booze or
they could also as most people are doing
now spending an Amazon yeah how do you
know they're going to a local craft
brewery yes honestly yes people spit has
spoken $1,000 a month for everyone over
eighteen but a value-added tax so you
can spend that thousand dollars on
value-added tax
well the value-added tax what end up you
still increase on the Oh God the bottom
ninety four percent of Americans this is
why there's and there's reality right
yeah by the way they tried this I
believe if I'm not mistaken in Canada in
Sweden with a Canada Sweden Canada and
Denmark and they immediately stopped it
yeah there's a normal program people
were up for something like forty four
percent of people dropped out from the
workforce yeah go to work a three-year
program and they stopped it after like
fifteen to eighteen months yeah I'm like
that if this is not working well
it turns out giving people free money
because some I think I said so this is
really not a good way to run the economy
yeah turns out well in look look there's
there's a video out there I think on
Amazon or Netflix looking or a European
swallow I don't know what do you I'm
gonna interrupt your point no no no I I
just think that innovation it's like
it's like bank tellers being pissed off
that ATMs came around right right it's
the all of these like horse and carriage
people basically got pissed off to the
car okay did that at net jobs to the
economy or did it take away by the way
we could also have people dig ditches
with spoons you'd have been right with
the ATM when I was a kid I thought the
ATM I just called it the money machine
yeah and I just remember my parents said
we can't afford that I would say the
name is Jim right interesting facts free
stuff Bernie Sanders still thinks that
he never grew out of that right you
never figured that when I hold a second
this is gonna cost us 18 trillion
dollars just got a machine yeah punch in
no no I don't think understand I don't
have any no no no you just need to punch
in not four-digit code that's not how it
works Bernie perhaps I'm not explaining
myself clearly there's a machine that
gives you money one would say that's its
sole purpose is to dispense Oh
[ __ ] cash Hey look Biden's honor he's
not raping anybody yes well give him
time give him time schools
swell I was like I wish you looked at
her WI want to hear that someone to see
what the interchanges something beyond
high school we should call the job thank
god there's a surplus well when they get
out they make it less than $25,000 a
year if you were to college and graduate
and make less than $25 on you but alone
I can only find you
I do like that we went from Hickenlooper
'z Jafar in the prison teeth to dentures
on Biden it very nice contrast like he
talks about people needing something
beyond high school you know you know why
that became a thing right a high school
diploma used to mean something in this
country right I know there's been
innovations and the demand for skills
but then it became College okay
everybody has to be shoved into college
right now and we have to subsidize it
which makes all the rates go up and now
you have useless college degrees so it's
post graduate degrees now what is Bernie
plumb pretties yelling about something
center Harris would you like to comment
on the fact that your career was started
by sleeping with a mayor what samosas we
continue into the next oh don't they
don't want to see a food fight they want
to know how we're gonna put food on the
table and she gets an applause they're
going to break I just here's the thing
that I and I know a lot of young people
right during the during the Bernie
broken Gang Gang I really feel like
they're pandering to losers tonight
honestly here's the big difference from
this in Republic whether you like Donald
Trump or not you say he's lying but
guess what his lie is predicated on the
idea you believe that he's lying to you
and telling you that you can be
independent it's great isn't it right
these kind of these great everyone you
can go out there and make your dreams
come true like he's lying
whereas these people are telling people
that they cannot make it yeah that
everything is stacked against them so
even then what do they have to do they
have to in order to win your votes they
have to keep you poor yeah they have to
keep you uneducated and fat and a
marginalized class that's why they keep
inventing them by the day it is
remarkable to be why are they not
talking about the vast majority of
Americans who pay off their debt either
immediately or don't accrue student debt
yeah where's your college what about
those people yeah by the way you want to
talk about people who are getting a
paying and net negative income tax
because of the federal transfers right
leg hang less than they're actually
receiving let's make students pay two
percent income tax hey
yeah this entire this entire debate thus
far has pandered to people who pay no
tax who contribute nothing to this
economy and if you were to watch this
you'd go hold on a second I get free
school I get free health care and a
thousand dollars in my pocket so someone
who started watching this debate going
man have to make some life decisions
maybe the underwater gender studies
basket-weaving at a local college isn't
the right way to go I should straight up
and fly right they tune into this and go
no I'm confident with my choices yeah
people have got good about this will
respond to the incentives that they're
given right and if you make an e and I
know people would say oh it's not a
Joule cigarettes they want they want
more and more and more government
control they're telling you that you
can't make it now we're not talking
about the extreme of somebody who has a
legitimate reason why they're in poverty
and all of the wonderful charity cases
out there or charity not cases but
charity charities out there that help
those we're talking about giving money
to everyone everyone just the people are
gonna vote no no their universal basic
income gives it to everyone now you end
up in a net loss if you're paying you
know a lot of money and you only get a
thousand back but you're paying twenty
thousand dollars a year because of the
new taxes you just talked about it being
three don't worry Bernie holler here now
and by the way you know what happens
with the VAT tax if you pay a sales tax
for your state it's on top of that and
guess what name me one place that's ever
had a bad tax that's aid gone down or
gone away it never happens being a vet
smells like Brautigan Bates himself in a
vat of gin this morning front line up
it's very similar I would call it
Medicare for all who want it you take
something like Medicare a flavor of them
in other words a public option by the
way Medicare drink I just did I was on
it will be not only a more inclusive
plan but a more efficient plan than any
of the corporate answers out there
really it will be a very natural glide
path to the single-payer and to
destruction remember
even in countries that have glidepath
right into the wall into the ground ii
burn even there there's still a private
sector that's fine it's just that for
our primary care actually that's not
necessarily true it is now for example
in Canada when I was there in Canada
they weren't allowed to have private
sector medicine right actually wasn't
allowed there was a Supreme Court case
in 2005 shall we versus Quebec and what
happened was there was this guy shall we
who was a doctor and he was actually
treating this is true Google is right
now shall we versus Quebec you can bring
this up so people need to understand the
only reason they allowed privatized
hospitals they call them in Canada super
hospitals we called them in United
States Hospital
the only reason they open them up was
because so many people were dying in the
face of wait lines as you know all
socialized health care countries by the
way they won't bring that up on The
Young Turks objective measurements are
worse than socialized health care
countries people were dying in this
location doctor shall we will pay you to
take care of us right and he did and he
was fine he was being shut down through
and the Supreme Court ruled it is a
violation of Human Rights to not allow
people who are essentially dying right
in our current health care system a to
pay for health care and so it opened it
up to privatized health care because
there were a record number of deaths
that by the way would not have occurred
in the United States so this idea that
well it's the only reason they allow
market driven insurance in these other
countries is because they have to
increase their system your new system
yes their system fails
how many third world countries became
great through socialism Haiti what's the
bar on that option private insurance and
floor insurance are no insurance
he's talking out of I mean I I literally
saw the difference between my dad's
health care before Obamacare and my mom
happen to make happen to go through the
same level issues all right during
Obamacare right break stands yeah I
oppose anyone who wants to take down
Obamacare yeah you got any kids
alright Bernie's about to get into this
let's hear something like that
California Vermont New York has
struggled with it Vermont had to stop
their programs so people don't realize
Vermont had basically uh socialized
health care program a single-payer
system that's not
you know can't do it every other major
country on Earth including my neighbor
50 miles north of me Canada somehow has
figured out a way now to provide health
care they provide crappy health care
it's like saying I provide a free lunch
to everybody and it's a ham sandwich or
a turkey sandwich by the way it's
actually just human [ __ ] in a sandwich
but you've been provided with a lunch so
don't complain be happy this is one
thing two people always say and you see
this and all the leftist websites they
say well they're Healthcare measurements
are actually better we're only ranked
36th or 46 the United States we're
ranked underneath Columbia and right
next to Slovenia okay
these metal mean right below Cuba by the
way these measurements come from
subjective polling where people say yeah
I'm satisfied with my health care but
when you look as it's free argue more
are you more or less likely to die from
serious diseases yeah what are the wait
times your best chance here is the
simple fact okay if you have a terminal
illness period if you are in Planet
Earth the single biggest determining
factor in your survival whether you're
rich poor black or white is do you live
in the United States yeah that's it
Conor Palin is it expensive short we
have a flawed system absolutely but
there is no doubt that the quality of
care is not only better the United
States but we're the only country
statistically pretty much that provides
virtually all medical innovation again
but that's a bad thing
what is Amazon or curing polio right but
well and it's it's a hard thing almost
impossible to go back from once you
switch the system over it's really hard
to build it back up to what it used to
be it's really hard to go back to a
system where I can go out and pick my
own insurance company because the
insurance companies kind of go away to
some degree in that right and the
hospital system starts to degrade so if
Canada right now wanted to switch
everything back over to kind of a
free-market system they probably
couldn't do it we heard you wrote a book
about yoga so how is it selling Matt
well Lester what you see yes Annelle
oh you know I forgot we do have to go up
pretty soon well I do want to hear
Williamson and then let's get Reuben on
the phone we have a Reuben coming up
here nice we can hashtag Crowder debate
stream you can sign up for mug club we
don't discount Coco and right now
because we're actually still backlogged
with other mugs and shipping that's our
juice I didn't join hind
well I was kind of calm slash my
beautiful can I get one of the broad
with a refill which could be fixed if
you aligned your chakras and rocked in a
tantric yogi position but what hot rocks
well whatever you do don't vaccinate
yourself my nationalized health care
solution English author mine national
health care solution Chinese cupping yes
her time has not expired not era fix the
national health care crisis by getting
rid of fracking sweetheart yes sir rule
read Jordan Peterson's book yes let me
know when we have a when we have a Dave
Rubin there on the phone and by the way
even hit the lower thirds there oh yeah
I can't say okay don't forget we have
our black african-american culture
appropriation that's true when they
bring up their about reparations here he
look like he's always sucked on half a
lemon I don't want you to screw up my
health care system that just leave it
alone no I don't think I need to live
alone I do think you need a signal I
mean they need to keep their hands off
that somebody else who's better equipped
to handle this needs to be the one
fixing it not them you guys leave it
alone easily man he looks like he had a
stroke hey does that stroke face hey we
don't know you don't know we don't know
if we dumpster fire
right here like you realize yeah but he
has a connection goes like it's so funny
[Music]
he his mouth looks like Dana Carvey
doing a character Manas lyric admitted
procedures man that is literally the
greatest description of everything ever
to the Bernie fingers but the Bernie
finger
it looks like the cover of that move was
that movie strangers yeah with the
hitting the door hit me doorbell that's
Bernie's finger now now I can't look at
Bennett without thinking like master of
the skies to 20/20 and out small well
somebody pay attention to me please and
I'm here because your insurance
companies right they're all they're all
greedy they only have a profit motive
but clearly everyone on this stage
Motum have never worked in the private
sector a day nor life outside of God
lover
Williamson wildly unsuccessful book they
all have inherently altruistic motives
so you would have to believe that every
single person who works at an insurance
company or a health sharing nonprofit
like we use with liberty health care
right yeah you would have to believe
that all of them are somehow evil but
everyone on this stage and the 42 others
on stage last night are for something
because they have addy next to their
name are inherently good-hearted yeah
absolutely and know what they're talking
about with this stuff but this would
actually work and make the outcomes
better for everybody and that's not true
it's never been proven anywhere as bad
as insurance is if I hate my insurance
right at all that all is probably
different insurance plans yeah if I hate
my insurance I can go to another plan
yeah that being said if they're
president certainly Bernie and certainly
not so I remember who has a Medicare for
versus universal health care versus
public options certainly Bernie
Elizabeth Warren Kamala Harris if they
had their way if the plan sucks yeah if
people would just focus on reducing the
cost of health care
stead of worrying about insurance all
right we have a guest actually I'm
deciding to bring him over interested uh
it's don't call him Pete but kick we
have Dave Rubin on the show mr. Lubin
can you hear me sir
yes Crowder can you repeat Mayor Pete's
life one second can we get him through
the speaker oh do I need a headphones
hold on one second there there Ruben is
there a way to get him coming out
through the speaker we are working on
that all right one second Dave Rubin for
some reason I'm not hearing you for one
second and the answer to that question
is but gig that's how we're pronouncing
his name I don't know because I keep
clicking the stupid thing oh yeah his
name is but gig well that's how I
pronounce it just because 30 gig once
yeah one second and if not you can just
a blare it from your headphones and I
can probably hear them they're sort of
like right I want to hear what what but
gig is saying cuz that'll be a good
segue program and we do ourselves no
favors by having 11 million undocumented
people in our country we shouldn't have
11 million undocumented people with no
pathway to citizenship it makes no sense
and the American people we should have
audio okay all right uh send your Dave
Rubin are you there sir Crowder how's
your Spanish me gusta me me gusta teeth
trimmer set at George Clooney
George Clooney in Syriana it's always
the exact same length I feel very good
about the trim well I wanted to trim
nicely for these fine Democratic
presidential candidates he's won't put
together these people who had only a few
minutes of watching this thing have
taken all of my money yes about a half
actually no sorry it's three-fifths of
the American economy lemansky this Dave
because you've obviously talked about
formerly being of The Young Turks and a
progressive back when you were more or I
guess a liberal in you're more of a
classical we get it we get it we get it
okay anyone here would there been at any
point your life anyone up here who you
think would have really appealed to you
who you would have voted for well it's
funny because
last night which was such an absolute
debacle and just not one interesting
remotely decent idea you know I hate
yeah I tweeted out this thing right are
they banned from saying freedom or
Liberty or of course capitalism like did
the D and say yeah DNC say you just
can't say that um when I was watching a
less than I really feel like fully how
these guys at that I mean out of this
crew you know I am yang Mambo and I
think it's a pretty decent has some
interesting ideas and by the way against
50 min a plate it's not for college I
mean some ideas of baptism with rattling
it and I think is it human you know no
it's more like a Democrat which it's not
really a anymore
I thought you mean like like Kennedy's
and that you know they rape but we're
not going back to look government is the
answer to every they want you're funny
they think they know how to life there's
no answer any problem that they don't of
government and I ants every problem
would just get the government not right
so you know here we are are man how do
you feel pita bud gig represents your
community white people community
I mean practicing homosexual community
does a genuine question when you got
married Dave because I've met by the way
I've spoken your husband and he's lovely
if you ever met and he's also named Dave
sorry I hope I'm not letting the Canada
bag but really fun guy I like I want a
party with with that dude you're you're
okay too but I have I have my charm how
did you guys determine them did you both
keep your names
well technically we could have slipped
right I could have taken his last name
and he could have taken my last name
would have been quite bizarre but no we
didn't we didn't do that he goes by
David anyway as a first name and I go by
David so okay you know it last name
because I found out that that Pete is
his husband took his name and so if he
go and search him it has it yeah
his husband has a very long last name
and so I was what I was you know listen
this is just a room full of sorry
straight guys were wondering how does
that work and it was in your question we
just decided we were just gonna keep our
names it's all good you know that makes
it easy uh here's the thing you just
mentioned it's sort of economically
right they want to take all of your
money and take over the economy now it
seems to me when you became more sort of
when you when you left the left you say
they left young you sort of came into it
more so from a free-speech angle but it
seems like you've gotten I hate to use
word progressively more sort of
economically libertarian or conservative
is that is that about right no that's
completely right I mean if anything
that's the one thing I say I've shifted
them most of the little thing I believe
in are the same things that I've always
and if you're able you can argue most of
dirt liberal Dean's say gay marriage and
we ignore them from libertarian
perspective which i think is much
thinner actually but the one place I'm
for sure is economic small business over
I understand how the top rate right
Allen by the way like um so long that
you know I've talked to lots of great
libertarian and Servet of economies and
their policies basically makes sense
they're not first but basically make
sense and the opportunity to do with
what want with your money and these guys
don't think I mean watching them right
now this is creating this clown car up
like they think that they don't how to
run your life better youth and it's make
it a problem these people would you
really want like I got a let me call
compiled you know it's like yeah I would
love to vote for a politician said I
don't hate you people I don't want any
new people these never thought I won't
mob don't bother me well that's that's
pretty much what Donald Trump says he
just says that once you turn your back I
like him I will never shake his head
especially fatty bread no Ethiopian food
today all right listen we do have to go
there because you eat with your hands
Ethiopian food I'm dying out here
back on the standard show I know you
want to get back to your viewing party
we appreciate it brother and I'm always
interested in hearing your viewpoint
Thank You Man Crowder I'm gonna go eat
Chinese food now I know
you think that somehow makes a but it's
just regular it doesn't make it k but
you know what it's going to be very much
like this debate in that once you're
done with it 15 minutes later you're
gonna want to do it all over again see
you Dave Rubin all right come on Harris
let's go to it it's really clicking then
we get to go to a commercial break
because I have to pee oh well there you
go
I really like dave rubin he's such a
nice guy nice guy I say I joke but these
are genuinely curious questions like how
many questions might ask you about being
a quarter black and white man when you
were being raised what was that like
where people surprised right the only
when we talked about bridging the racial
divide you don't have to act colorblind
right in the truth is the only way you
learn of these things good smooth manny
back there yeah I don't know anything
about Columba aside from Shakira in
Pablo Escobar he teaches me right that's
it that's the king oh geez
all right let's see what she's pounding
the podium Rosie calmly this just means
she got noticed notably blacker she did
she brought she popped out the Ebonics
came here illegally whoa yes that wasn't
illegal
coming here Hickenlooper may more like
Hickenlooper you look watch it's too far
in the it's too far in the the prison
cell watch one honey
me huh at least he knows to keep his
mouth closed when he's not talking cuz
he's like just don't show them the
chompers what stopped saying that
they're all asking for asylum far in the
Aladdin prison it does it has that angle
boat for John Hickenlooper he looks like
an eagle you saw the problem we talked
about the crisis right now the only way
you solve it is if you make sure they
can't come in yes if you make sure
there's a wall is if you make sure you
secure our borders listen it's just it's
just like not disciplining a kid it ends
up being far worse than down the line if
you let people in you have to put them
somewhere you have to be something with
these people and what do they want they
want to just let everyone be granted
immunity of American citizens
and close the books yeah we're saying
don't look the men in the first place
yeah and by the way we're talking about
people in cages again that goes back to
Clinton the floors consent policies
Barack Obama violated because he saw it
as an incentive to discourage illegal
immigration by caging kids with their
parents I want to make sure we
understand this yeah it was okay we need
it yeah I know it's increased
drastically they'll say well it's
increased drastically since Donald Trump
became president because we had a
hundred thousand illegal immigrants in
March and by the way do you know why
more because the economy is better yeah
how does people talk about the crisis of
mass migration while not acknowledging
the reason for the crisis of mass
migration and if you've got a problem
where you have too many undocumented
people that live here and by the way
that's a problem for them too they live
in a shadow economy they can't call on
justice to help them if they're being
robbed or if they're being exploited in
some way because they're living in the
shadows they'd be deported so they get
taken advantage of all of the time so
it's bad for them it's bad for everybody
the first thing you would do is close
the door you know where they are let's
just make sure nobody else comes in do
you know where they don't have this
crisis Finland you know figured this out
Israel they built a wall what was it a
couple million dollars per mile they
built like a hundred yes it's not
entirely appropriate you know because of
rockets and terrorists but get it out
they had people coming in that they
wanted to make sure didn't come in they
had a problem they solved that problem
yes for the most part right what is she
saying right now to buy her book crazy
things something about getting gays and
AIDS and like prayer and just happy
thoughts
crazy broad would try to cure your HIV
with like a with lavender oil right yeah
just put some testing on it you think
you make some frankincense and your look
cry it's in my book some eucalyptus on
your ballsack you your syphilis will be
a thing of the past but I've
transitioned seller Williams is one of
those people where I see claims that
people say things in Twitter I'm like I
guess that could be true I don't know
like sorry so hello I'm out I'm out
you're out
thank you very much golly you guys are
drinkers whoa whoa whoa almost had a
careful down careful or what well the
ones got to give you a fresh one in the
kitchen we want to pay for lawyers for
asylum seeker
so let's rack up the bill right now oh
boy free health care free education
thousand dollars for everybody right
thank you very much and now lawyers for
illegal immigrants now how about this
the first safe country you arrive to is
where you have to apply for asylum first
and foremost if you're not from Mexico
and you're applying for asylum the line
starts a little to the south yeah you
know what apply there I hate to say but
that would backfire because there is no
safe military the Mexico relatively
speaking is not a war zone right they're
not a country that is in a state of war
I said I realize there may be drug
cartels but there's still places that
you can go I'm sorry they know I'm
talking about there are talking dogs
yeah talking dogs
what the Dagda complete eggs oh well I
imagine Slyke I'm constipated with
anybody needs preparation-h I do
hey because it is dead wrong your
presidency is dead that's true itself in
the language of religion really now if
you like to cloak yourself in the stem
cells launched in a church and state and
we stand for people of any religion any
people of no religion but we should call
out hypocrisy when we see it and for a
party that associate sit self with
Christianity to say that it is hate to
suggest that God would smile on the
division of families at the hands of
federal agents that said that no who's
that win how about 32-week abortions but
gig that you support how about how about
every senator here who voted against the
infant the babies born alive act which
is just guaranteed health care to babies
who were already born from surviving
botched abortions
do you think God smiling on that yeah oh
you're saying that God has a problem
with rule
of law like borders do you think by the
way you thank god this is remarkable to
me
they act like like there was no
pragmatism in the Bible here I think
that Jesus didn't have a basic
understanding of geography Jesus of
Nazareth golly
what do you want when he rode an
attendant donkey in the public it is
just riddled with geographical and tough
typographic references yes of course
well and by the way I can't believe that
he just called on the name of God to say
I can't believe that we would have
children separated from their families
that is not Chris either way three
drinking here and afternoon and he said
my party doesn't talk about religion a
lot because we believe in the separation
of church and state
really apparently you don't know what
that is I'm gonna drink oh sorry I did I
just did my mug hey Pete but Kay here's
a copy of the Constitution find those
words for me yeah thank you anywhere it
was so that we would not impose a state
religion it's like you guys don't know
anything about history and probably more
likely to roll up the Constitution and
stick it on its own hole with a German
gonna say something about Romans I'm
just saying he looks like Richard Gere
just think we got a trump tweet here our
president is tweeting right now what all
Democrats just raised their heads for
giving millions of illegal aliens a
little bit of health care how about
taking care of American citizens first
exclamation and question mark that's the
end of that race and they're gonna go
back to Donald Trump he's a racist
of course yes yeah because he's
pragmatic about it hundred thousand
people last month in metastatic a you
know something like like he was
obviously talking about the Democratic
race for presidency I guarantee you
tomorrow morning the the thing that he
was talking about Mexicans hey yes
gerald can you move your hat from the
clock I can't see our actual clock that
he puts his hat above the climate any
vote let me put it on the camera how
about that that worked for you shouldn't
you have been assassinated by now the
play is still going on can someone get
us my man where is it assassin usually
is one article to me
you know they talk about hillary clinton
right she was uh they said she lost the
election and she lost the minutes which
surprised me surprised was michigan
until i realized that how the cozy
relationship that Donald Trump had was
sort of pandering to unions by the way
the biggest political donors
yeah I think he would lose those same
states to Bernie but the reason I think
Bernie would beat Donald Trump the way
Donald Trump beat Hillary if he were to
win I think it's a 50-50 shop I'm saying
if Bernie wins that's how he wins I
don't I don't think Biden has that path
to victory
I think Biden loses the same states that
Hillary wins now here's here's what's
happening because they were seen as an
elitist party not looking out for the
best interests of Americans here's what
they've done they've swapped the elitism
that you saw with Hillary Clinton right
and the big donor class and basically
the big Democratic elites and they've
swapped that in not looking out for
Americans in being an elitist party to
illegal immigrants and non contribute so
Americans don't feel like they're
looking out for their best interests now
they're just not looking out for the
donor class they're looking out for the
non donor non citizen class and that's
why though I really think that a guy
like Bernie Sanders wins New York in
California and he does horribly in swing
states because of his policies I don't I
don't think there's a lot of a lot of
support for his stuff I think a lot of
the support that he's getting is just
like it was last time in the primaries
and that's it can I just hear what the
question of transit what are they
answering right yes yes they should be
heads up
we do have dancringe choice and in a
video oh okay
you know what okay hold on since you're
going on about immigration we're gonna
take a quick break break again hashtag
Crowder debate oh we have tributes so if
contributor right now winner will be
announced later on winner of the costume
contest winner trivia and the person who
sends in the most American video you can
possibly record right now we're going to
a break this Jim Norton this is this is
Jim Norton who's sent in a video with
the most American thing he could first
trivia is what a cigar did Bill Clinton
famously used tweet your answers at us
Crowder and the winner I guess we'll
probably AB average it up there at the
end you'll win something I don't know
you'll win we'll take a DNA scraper full
of Gerald's half beard here today there
we go Jim Norton right now and a quick
break with the most American that you
can think of we'll be back after this
with John Stossel
- all concerned
happy 4th of July to the louder with
Crowder mug club I think my favorite
thing about being an American the
quality in us tonight cherished the most
is how we talk about valuing free speech
while at the same time joining a social
mob and targeting and trying to cancel
[Applause]
cancel a person who says something we
find objectionable we value free speech
but only our own I think that's my
favorite quality as a nation is our
staggering lack of self awareness and
despite talking a good game in the end I
did not have the balls to wear this hat
happy 4th of July from Lady Liberty
standing in the harbor to the sheer
majesty of the Grand Canyon all the way
to Donald Trump's historic electoral
victory
everywhere you turn is a reminder that
this country is better than yours our
food tastes that much sweeter our women
are that much hotter and our teeth are
that much straighter so please stop by
come say hello do a keg stand in the
parking lot and join us as we all give a
collective middle finger to England as a
reminder that we are never ever ever
ever getting back together
a place that's pure America
a happy fourth of July to all the folks
from the louder with Crowder mug club I
can't think of nothing more American
than swinging the lead baby here we go
America coming up through our fourth of
July break louder with Crowder's
American history masterclass featuring
historian David Barton hosted by yours
truly each day we'll dive into a new
topic complete with context and
one-of-a-kind historical artifacts that
I'll try desperately not to break
in-depth discussions on the history of
the First Amendment the Second Amendment
the Revolutionary War and the history of
the United States name that's a new
installment each day all week July 1st
through 5th don't miss it unless you
hate America
in which case please do
[Music]
[Music]
louder with prouder Ranger panties buy
yours today at louder with Crowder shop
calm attention if you or a loved one has
been diagnosed with mesothelioma you may
be entitled to superior drinking vessel
mesothelioma is a rare cancer linked to
asbestos lined monochrome metal tumblers
inhaling in the vicinity of these
energetic canisters may have put you at
risk go to louder with Carter calm / bug
Club now for a girthy hand ash mug that
for all we know probably cures cancer
that's louder with Carter calm / Mudd
Club don't hesitate once again that's
louder with Crowder calm / mug club join
now and Jim Creator oh yeah duct tape Oh
Doug baby close the second door treat
the studio like a dark room oh my people
bringing their babies here wrong it's
just wrong has that even happened tell
you what that's where I'm hopefully
gonna get to the Planned Parenthood
discussion soon and you could learn a
thing or two
Wow me into a person that I just don't
like myself maybe I do need Marion
Williamson's book maybe a little bit
maybe everything you're giving but gig a
lot of airtime by the way Esther now
alright God hates taxes wait see by
these hand gonna because nose like that
is investing so that they could soon be
able to run circles around us in
artificial intelligence and this
president is visualize on the finer
relationship is if all that mattered was
the export balance on dishwashers we got
a much bigger issue on our hands really
when they're authoritarian model is
being held up by and talking up as fast
as like it's because this is what I
would do if it were consensual right now
because by the way you know the biggest
issue with China right now since
dealing our intellectual property and
our own that's one of the arguments for
having very hard to do enslave that are
backed over by the way for people we're
going to be on break no more life until
August first
so do follow me on Instagram is a lot of
credit Instagram it is it's what because
yes Steven Carter was taken master
they're coming back up this well they're
taking a break and now they're having a
break we can have John Stossel come up
in a couple of minutes it is oh by the
way you know what a tribute sorry I've
so many things one famously use the
grand reserve Gurkha cigar tweet your
Realtors s crowd Amos Lee famous
allegedly no it's just well known
famously has anything surprised you yet
anything so far stood out a guy we've
been watching it we have teeth no
honestly honestly like I am amazed at
people who don't even consider looking
presidential yes look nearly is
remarkable to me these things matter I
think the funniest thing so far is young
is like listening and like way what what
you say right I don't know we got the
dancringe out video you want to do that
real quick or do we have that right what
is the damn video well Dan Chris sent us
in a video so we can go to that here's a
video in French is the most American
thing you can think of no he was
supposed to be here but Nancy Pelosi
screwed it up forever yeah that's true
Nancy Pelosi she ruined her no that's
right she did I don't like her even more
I'm already sure that Nancy Pelosi like
if I had to bet my bottom dollar she
smacked him around like the pharmacist
in It's a Wonderful Life with bud gig
I'm pretty sure that yeah pretty sure
that Nancy Pelosi at some point put rat
poison in the wrong pill and she crushed
his eustachian tube am I just crushed my
own crenshaw really quickly not gonna
like it
hey guys sorry I couldn't be with you we
had late votes
I hope you are looking forward to
another democratic debate where they can
try out their crazy language skills and
prove to everybody that they do not in
fact speak the language they're trying
to speak that was probably my favorite
part from last night's debate anyway
happy fourth of July it's coming up and
I want to show you the most American
thing I can think of which is beating
our favorite Canadian and deadlifting
destroying his his best deadlift here it
is
[Music]
wait is he wearing white or black I
don't know by the way you just got small
down no he is stronger than me in the
demo I can't do it my wrist and he's
like people don't realize because the
camera adds ten pounds he's four foot
nine if you were not Daniel Crenshaw is
a very good-looking guy because he was
actually an understudy at the CW network
he would be positively dwarfed by Andrew
yang and Pete butt-kick if you were
stayed in the line you should be
stronger if you're a bigger man in fact
it's actually how he got his job start
den creature did you know this
represented an Crenshaw he was actually
picked out he was just at the police
station was in a lineup
well no but gay committed the sexual
assault and Dan creature just happened
to be there because they matched size
but the pot I know it can't be done
crunch that guy's far too little yeah
it's a butt kick he's not four times you
out and you resort to insulin cringe I
really but he's doing the deadlift you
know why he's cuz he can't he can't do
the squat challenge because he he has he
has poor depth perception and we're
bringing in the weights now by the way
though you got so much crap for the
squatting technique even though it was
correct
well I back in the show cuz that's
probably the meanest we love you Dan
joke you can make my fringe we love you
Dan Crenshaw maybe he got crap for his
deadlift but lots of compliments on your
ass it's true well he's squatting his I
blades Award was thick with two seas
yeah yeah okay so do followed on
Instagram I think it took three
commercial breaks in rapid succession
well if they're realizing that their
show sucks which by the way here's
something else that I find cuts are
pretty quick he'll be coming back yeah
can we get John Stossel any we're gonna
be on style so up in a minute one thing
that I do find funny is uh they have
Rachel Maddow on you know they say Chris
Matthews and Rachel Maddow who's doing
it to yesterday mady's was on earlier
today okay but they said Maddow remember
when people were upset that Candy
Crowley asked a bias question yeah to
Mitt Romney nearly having people like
Maddow
I think that was during the presidential
yeah yeah but the other thing is you
know I don't look problems regimental
moderating a Democrat debate but if Sean
Hannity moderated a Republican debate
region right I would go bananas yeah
it's true I think he policy that'd be
the better way to do it have somebody
from the other side ask the opposing
party appointed question instead of
these softball layups that we're hearing
here and now Thomas which one's the man
let's hear the using actually Rachel
Maddow is being a good at her job I no
problem I think she's sharp still
camping I think she expresses the
leftist point of view pretty effectively
I think she's wrong but I actually think
that Rachel Maddow is probably the best
amongst the left today yeah
we can grab stuff and I do want to hear
them though for a couple of seconds
don't worry the audience reaction that
would notify Susie Adam because these
answers suck please clap even though we
know that Buddha Tyrion we have done
stones but we have John Stossel all
right senior this is actually you know
when people ask me if they talk about
our show obviously not tonight this is a
live debate but they say what has
influenced your program if you had to
describe it what I always say is the two
biggest influences young early David
Letterman yes and this man John Stossel
because I used to watch the giving a
break segments after TGIF and I was a
kid and I didn't know what conservatism
is awesome and I just when he would go
out and go give me a break I do I like
this guy I don't know what it is about
it and then I bought his book
immediately so one of the biggest
influences of this show I don't know if
he'll be proud of that or ashamed mr.
John Stossel thank you for being here
sir
happy to be here but what's a
conservative a libertarian I don't know
what you before and he said classical
liberal and all this stuff so I okay
libertarian I apologize
by the way when I said David Letterman
in Stossel I meant Letterman and Hugh
Downs are you watching this tonight
mister Stossel off and on I took a
relief rank to walk the dog okay yeah
I've been watching and what has been
your read on this
thus far I hate them all that doesn't
sound very libertarian politicians they
just pander they just offer people free
stuff they're economically so ignorant
I just makes me hate politicians even
more well we can we can tally up the
bill right tonight we have free
healthcare for all we have free college
for all yes and then we have lawyers for
all asylum seekers and of course a path
to citizenship reparations I would
imagine you're probably going to have
some sort of installment here in the
future tallying up this bill that seems
right up your alley just adding this up
and having a receipt yeah I could do
that for one of my new 500 videos which
is what I do now every week but before
we go into that I would like to know
who's the guy to your left this is John
Prada and one of my writers wonderful
man he's he is George Washington but
it's not the Washington you know this is
President Washington not general and
he's also drunk yes a little bit well
stone-cold sober which is not a good way
to walk you never play our drinking
games you know how much I know about you
John sauce is gonna creep you out okay
uh I know how you keep fit okay
volleyball I know that when you get them
all wrong yes beach volleyball sorry I'm
sorry I didn't know the moon set and I
know because it uses your stabilizing
muscles that's how he keeps his felt I
know that people are jealous of your
metabolism because when you come home
after work you've talked about how you
eat as much popcorn and chocolate as you
want do you still do that by the way I
do but I don't eat breakfast so I don't
eat anything for one yeah that makes it
that makes it okay
I just reading everything I was a
voracious reader of your books when I
was a kid and and good judge yes yes
well this is what happened after we
watched the breed of the Teenage Witch
and then 20/20 would come on and I
remember going oh that's a guy who
probably pisses everyone else off at the
ABC halls and and and now it's now where
can people see your five-minute videos
you were talking about John Stossel
where's the best place for people to see
it
just Google John Stossel we make a video
every week it's nice and concise like
the old give me a break day it's not the
long podcast thing like you it's just
concise what you need to know but we're
still working on the lighting here yeah
I was gonna say I haven't opened up
behind you it looks like it looks like
this is some kind of a Shh homemade
makes you fry alien culture is that
Marianne Williamson is guru behind you
is it will just my new assistant Rebecca
she's a libertarian and we don't know
you know I'm in my apartment
lighting is this know to make you know
this working on skype and all that
yeah it's newfangled technology John
this is that's these things change that
being said you are light years ahead of
Bernie let me ask you this final
question because we do have to get going
pretty soon and by the way I just we
just checked if you google john stott
and google google immediately suggests
john stossel illuminati so don't do that
let's let's give them the direct blog
received yeah James O'Keefe kind of had
he kind of had a lead on that I've
already about any searches in Google who
do you think is the nominee or do you
think it's too early to tell mister
Stossel well it's clearly too early to
tell and who I think is sort of
irrelevant but the best guy he's got the
polls but the Fedders because anybody
could say I think it's this person but
the people who put their money where
their mouths are begin enough of those
people and you go to the bookies and
calculate the odds it's not perfect but
it's the most accurate predictor but I'm
just putting it up on my phone it's hard
to see here isn't it it's very visible
election betting odds com it says by
this a 27% he's down 1.2% in the last
hour though I didn't think done so badly
Elizabeth Warren is off like a scientist
ought to do well last night it's 16% way
behind Harris at 14% way behind so have
you have you placed a bet yourself
say again have you played
to bet yourself you know we Americans
can't legally do it except small amounts
on predicted yeah but you're a
libertarian since when has that stopped
you we do try to obey the laws while we
complain about pretty much just talk
about pot and Bitcoin but no III all
drugs should be legal once you're an
adult it should be your right to ingest
whatever the hell you want john stossel
i believe that but i remember i've made
the argument of the thanksgiving table i
camera which book was in where you were
the one introduced me to this that
someone should be allowed to sell their
kidney if they want to and i think you
made the point that when you think of a
kidney donor you think of an organ donor
the surgeon is making money the person
is receiving the transplant is obviously
benefiting from it the only person who
is not compensated in this transaction
is the one who's giving up an organ and
that made me become more libertarian huh
that's true well whatever works because
another good example lots of people died
because something like a hundred
thousand people are waiting for kidneys
and we have donors who do it out of
altruism but it's not enough so why not
give people money they say oh poor
people will make bad decisions well poor
people have free will too but if
somebody wants to say I'd rather have
seventy thousand bucks than one of my
kidneys
yeah I think they don't know how that
works with Medicare for all at that
point it seems like a free-for-all where
basically you wake up in a tub full of
ice and a sore back all right we do have
to get going on having a lower third
there mr. stossel for people to go find
your content we want to have you back on
the show soon I really appreciate you
making the time
fix the stone-cold sober go go go mix it
up sir yeah I'll do what I can
all right thank you very much be well
and it looks like Harris let's bring us
up is getting into it with Biden today
they look like the battle ramping
you say I support the IRA er I've also
argued very strongly that we in fact
deal with the notion of denying people
access to the ballot box I agreed that
everybody once day in Swedish we do that
my times up on so thank you yeah your
time is up because it's like someone
who's you in the fight like hold me back
hold me back nobody hold you back oh I
would have nailed that kid of this field
on the stage diversity drink all right
any one of the broads amount bring us
back up the drinking rules there real
quick there quarter black card if we can
for people who don't know hash tag crowd
or debate stream a lot of words bernie
hits here white what America is about
three times three times people from the
GPL poising let's bring out a tribute
let's bring out a trophy boy here we go
it's so girthy I think we brought
alright listen that was a social justice
warrior phrase of the night he hit nine
of a drinking game words everybody home
sending what you're drinking I think are
you helping him there Gerald or no no
they got it doing a thing alright and
here we go social justice where your
phrase the night
[Applause]
ya see I'm gonna try my best Joe Biden
yeah yeah yeah what she's over the age
of 18 had a concussion two weeks before
he did as we complained and Valdez well
he fell off the donkey it's dangerous
being you or working for you sorry I
should say all right thanks Abe Lincoln
you horndog but I suppose you'll be
gonna say I consider your wife so I
watch listen she's she's a [ __ ] not my
wife Abe Lincoln's wife the guy had half
the country against him and his wife
okay play with us yeah it was a tough
one she was she was no peach like whoa
whoa you are so getting a Saturday when
you get home by I feel like you know -
Maximus that'd be I have to drink
something here clearly the least dusty
pig in the room all right all right
pumpkin that's enough you know why you
should be mad is that this is how we
make a living just think if they were
talking substitute policy we couldn't do
this we'd actually have to listen to all
they're talking about gerrymandering
yeah here's the thing I do have a
problem with gerrymandering I really do
that thinks that some someone is going
to the terms that are racist her line
someone's going to determine again we're
gonna go back to geography
they don't believe that people should
have to be citizens to vote effectively
yes so don't try and get all high and
mighty when you talk about changing
voting demographics when you don't
believe that someone should have to
present the same ID they would if they
wanted to purchase this keg to vote
or to go and check out a book in the
library or get on an airplane perhaps
come on I I just get annoyed against a
lot of people who think Jerry Manning is
like the biggest issue only discovered
it in 2010 right like we haven't been
Jerry but politically gerrymandering
states we have for a long time I mean I
mean there are there are districts in
New York City that I swear cut through
apartment buildings no it makes sense I
get it if you if you change a district I
get it right they don't like it but
sometimes it does make sense to change a
district that the dynamics change a
little bit so go for it I don't care and
they didn't say the Supreme Court didn't
say anything other than we're not gonna
we're not gonna rule on this just send
it back he'll say the reason I think cuz
John sauce was talking about maybe we
can bring the volume up a little bit the
reason Joe Biden lost some points is
this kind of king of the hill and
something everyone's going after him not
because he's at the top but you know
what it's pretty easy to attack Joe
Biden here's why because there's a
contrast between Barack Obama and Donald
Trump and everyone knows that that's a
weak spot because the country was in a
much worse situation with Barack Obama's
president so my proxy they can copy
paste that on to Joe Biden right now
he's having to defend all of Obama's
crappy policy yeah and no one else
really has to yeah that'll be the thing
that brings him down if he gets the
nomination one of the things by the way
don't you love that Barack Obama didn't
endorse someone he's like him too and
then I walked on down to Amy's diner
[Music]
doesn't the sitting president usually
not endorse huh no they usually do like
I don't think Reagan and doe Reagan
endorser and during the Bush 42.3 does
get it does get a little dicey with the
west wing address this Steven but he's
not he's not the sitting president
Barack Obama no I are you talking about
now are you talking about before oh okay
gotcha yeah well I think it's too early
for an endorsement anyway right so if he
comes down to like the last four or five
people then I would miss introduced him
along a little bit while he's doing it
so what happens if you're Obama and you
endorse him and all this sudden he loses
like what you got a pick between the
people you didn't endorse to endorse I
mean it can be a little embarrassing
into the hands of the voters oh shut up
and they can't catch a break here
there's like perpetually the people call
I got son of a gun man did you notice
yesterday when they ask Cory Booker to
name specific I have companies he said
Amazon and Halliburton like what
happened
Halliburton pays why did you how far
back did you have to reach for that
[ __ ]
yeah like it's the Halliburton I
remember when George Bush was president
that was the cat that was a caliber
Halliburton yeah but what about
Halliburton okay okay we good rating
this should we gotta hear this this is
abortion which makes sense to the
Supreme Court during your presidency if
you're elected president what is your
plan
if row is struck down in the court while
you're president well my plan is
somebody who believes for a thought that
a woman's right to control her own body
is a constitutional to cooking and
politician should not infringe on that
right we will do everything by the way
this is something they talk about
they're trying to let's be really clear
about that they're trying to set up as
narrative that these states are extreme
right these states are extreme because
they have heartbeat bills or they have
some kind of restrictions on abortion
and by the way I think which one state
doesn't make exceptions for rape and
incest and the other ones do Georgia's
the child it's tough to keep track of
Georgia Alabama what he just said is no
restrictions on abortions period Bernie
Sanders believes in abortion up to nine
months and if it's inside the birth
canal and keep in mind every single
person on the stage who had the ability
to vote voted against the babies born
alive yes simply would protect babies
who had already survived abortions and
already been born well they try to
portray this as though the heartbeat
bill is super extreme let's be clear
here these people many of whom receive
all kinds of funding from pro-abortion
organizations planned parent themselves
and I've pushed against any roll backs
to abortion just 220 weeks every single
person who could vote on this on this
stage supports abortion up until the
moment of birth and in many cases after
birth if they've survived and attempted
before
yeah so let's be clear about who the
extremist is here that's most important
and if you're one of those people that
is going down to the border for a photo
shoot in an all-white outfit crying with
rage $1,000 watch right yeah we had a
parking line she could've got yeah at a
parking lot that turned out not to be
the thing if you're upset about people
having migrant children being kept in
cages quote unquote you better be pissed
off about a child being born and left on
a table to die yeah there is no excusing
that I think and by the way on on
abortion aren't we one of like 10
countries in the world that allow it
after 20 weeks nine yeah the only
country like that and China on the list
North Korea and China were one of very
very few countries who actually have
abortion as far as we do including by
the way no most nations in Europe and
it's before most states do yeah and
people like to let some kind of crazy
right-wing time so that's really good
how far the leftist yeah exactly
well this is false premise that we're
trying to control women's bodies no
we're just trying to say don't kill
babies if it please tell me your
Williamson's opinion on this I feel like
she would support like live dolphin
Bertha yeah where you like give birth
nature knows had it how to help you take
its course like they would have dolphin
that was an actual thing would have
dolphins deliver babies really yeah but
then the dogs started stealing kids
what is this shape of water and like
stealing kids it really offensive pricks
and they were remote controlled by Biden
it was an actual thing doing they just
kind of gave that one to Trump you're
saying who would you want to negotiate a
deal the whole premise of this question
is is wrong it says okay if if row gets
overturned in the what I'm sorry in the
oh the co-equal branch of government
that handles this the the courts right
you can't do anything if all they're
gonna do basically is say it goes back
to the states that's it they're gonna
give the states full power to take care
of it also shows how little Bernie knows
about the law there is no constitutional
right to abortion now it's about privacy
if you want really what a constitution
Oh climate change tryna dad Rice's worse
that's to know our collective Oh science
fiction
you mean like chopping off your [ __ ] and
calling yourself a woman right is that
what you mean you mean like Florida was
supposed to be gone but everyone looks
like a Space Odyssey Spielberg alien
with just a copy no genitalia that kind
of science fiction's that what you're
talking about
you mean the guy who doesn't believe the
people who said that Florida was gonna
be gone we'd have record right great
lake droughts record highs and by the
way oh yeah
sea levels pretty much fine and I'm
pretty sure Florida still there last I
checked yes so you want to save migrants
worth the border right you want to save
them yeah by the way people who are
basically staying at a Holiday Inn
Express okay it's like NASA camp because
they have to use some of that that cheap
plastic blanket I know I went to Space
Camp was a kid it's not very compatible
it's like putting a microwave food top
cover on you as a blanket this is what
the spaceman used and here's some dried
ice cream like this sucks I want to go
home yeah sure I understand their plight
but she just said she wants to bring us
back into the Paris Accord of the co2
protocol Paris Accord it was a Montreal
agreement Kyoto Protocol and Paris the
climate Accord yeah guess what you'll be
killing millions of people from third
world countries yeah now of course what
is that when you look at things like the
carbon tax that's passed on lobule don't
know this guess we get that gets passed
on to people who disproportionately pay
for energy heating gas middle class
people middle class people will be hit
by things like the Paris of the Paris
Accord more than anyone else in this
country while we're talking about the
billionaire class but guess who's going
to be hitting more than American
middle-class people in third world
countries who have to work in entire
months just so they can have enough fuel
to hopefully cook a can of beans over an
ironing board put over a barrel garbage
can fire yeah these people don't
understand it would be a hard-ass
traffic it will kill people and
equalities carbon would cost trillions
of dollars and scientists hold on we
need to go back to science because
that's what she said scientists have
even come out and said this won't solve
the problem even if everybody does every
single thing that we've said to do right
and by the way China is in no way shape
or form going to do everything that they
were told to do nothing
I listen to the science guy okay no he's
talking about we can't get them to raise
kids Nike factory by a nickel we're
supposed to believe that they're going
to completely stop halt
full stop their Industrial Revolution
yeah we'll get right on that
yeah tell you what have your your yang
gank all my yang gang they're gonna
start hacking to get yang yes that's why
is getting so much time he really is
he keeps saying local communities he's
like what the wannabe craft brew of the
candidate he's what he's the governor of
Indiana right yeah there's only one
major city the rest are just local small
towns okay I spent some idea is just
what we trying to say I'm trying to say
that he doesn't have any major cities
Indianapolis doesn't count Gary Gary is
the murder capital of the world really
no capita is that is that one
Hickenlooper a Bennett this is jicama
that took a look broken okay let see
what he has to say
I didn't literally mean 10 or 12 years
and Hickenlooper didn't get the memo
[Laughter]
let's talk about wind and solar it
doesn't work you can look to Germany and
France an example German Germany tried
to make all their energy come from a new
this is a thing yeah I all of us here
wants the earth to be cleaner yes I
always think you shouldn't be taught the
window we've got yeah yes that being
said Germany tried to move to renewables
namely wind and solar guess what it
didn't work power brownouts and then
they have power surpluses cuz he can't
have a battery grid that works to store
that kind of power they'll sell it a net
negative price compare that to France
who's mostly what now what now but no
everyone say together nuclear energy and
they're almost entirely energy
independent by the way nuclear energy
uses three hundred times less creates
three hundred times less toxic waste
right per unit energy right created then
solar and solar and by the way
that radioactive isotopes have a
half-life yeah
the toxic that landfill that's created
from solar how do you think they get
these unbelievably expensive rare
materials the minor that they do it
doesn't work there's a great example
here if they wanted to talk about safe
it independent or if they want to talk
about energy independence yeah oh I
think we have a Hopf American flag
American flag attaboy now I'm distracted
because buddy I know you love the United
States but the problem is they're gonna
say you're a missus look you don't want
to watch the movie Chernobyl the series
Chernobyl on HBO and think that tells
you everything that you need to know
about nuclear go to a country that
actually does it and implements it and
does it say something Noble reassure
nobody on our staff to read up Chernobyl
Fukushima more their fear actually I
think I have this written down because I
haven't really gone any of these sources
here you have I don't know where it's
it's one of those things but it's
actually safer there lots of lots and
lots and lots of people died there's a
number I think that you're gonna be able
to pull up a statistic that shows that a
lot more people okay I forget the death
rate is guess what the death rate is for
solar ok solar and wind compared to
nuclear five five guess how many times
higher it is the nuclear per kilowatt
hour I'm gonna go with ten four thousand
times higher Wow Wow yeah this comes for
a lot higher than forth the death rate
is four thousand times yes it's four
thousand times higher for for wind and
solar than for nuclear power plants yeah
most of the the fallout from Chernobyl
of these places there was a possibility
that some people had thyroid cancer yeah
but the deaths that occur think of the
different steps in erecting these solar
panels and wind turbines the mining
needed for the materials there are pairs
the fact is it doesn't work it's
unreliable it's expensive nuclear
creates no waste virtually basically
waste can be stored for just a little
bit of a small amount of time and it's
it creates no comment well and there are
plants that can actually recycle
part of that waste and reuse it so they
cut down big time on the waste and if
you're if you're worried about chernobyl
saying that thousands and thousands of
people died or were affected by if they
were but guess what you were no they
learned there were not thousand oh there
were not thousands of people who died
yes there were no
there were less than a hundred
attributable to the actual explosion but
afterwards there were thousands of
people that had their lawyer they
lecture he revised those numbers they
didn't revise them down below thousands
but let me make my point my point is it
was soviet-controlled Russia they didn't
do anything right the problem with this
is that they didn't want to look stupid
don't do that to Bernie he's like it was
a horrible like if it happened in France
it wouldn't be the same thing they would
call that flying
it was just burning having some bad gas
after burritos right yeah jeez so you
can be done well and he can save a lot
of money and save a lot of lives hold on
Williams and say something crazy oh here
we go doing nothing that was a please
shut up motivating people that's like if
a personal trainer we're running for
president oh she said green new deal
she said green new deal sorry drink hep
drink have we heard from Andrew yang
since the first question no he's sitting
over there loves done you know what we
could cut to the concentration camp camp
oh yeah you know actually right now most
American thing we can think of let's go
live really quickly to the concentration
camp it all seems as though a propeller
cam fortune would be impractical given
the large climate in Reverse yes but the
lollies you can't fly there it's a great
almost usual that would not be shouldn't
be ones first choice no it almost would
be a giveaway and make noise probably it
could almost be it almost make one more
visit stop it you and shiny things after
timepiece whoa whoa are they closing
Namjoo kanou-kun now where's the
reparation she's just saying stuff that
she wants for herself
hold on my reparations man which Donald
Trump did reparation Oh guns you just
don't like guns
[Laughter]
he's getting older and crazier
he's like the guys at the Bob Evans
early bird special you're like you can't
say that about black people right now
you have a joke on my husband you're
done Yankees he's out of this I would
pronounce it well before the election to
make sure we don't realize the worst
president in American history tell about
the economy dummy oh she's a homeless
lady
they put makeup on her and a dress that
you two can go from pooping in streets
to peeing on two-faced stage well you
don't even some Sam you know it you know
it make it great for a peeler oh you
know a great country for if you don't
kill them
when when they're about to be born that
would be fantastic perfect we're gonna
go to a quick break we have some trivia
before we go to the break by the way
send in your videos the most American
thing to think of costume contest
winners will be reading them pretty soon
um trivia before the break is who freed
the slaves American trivia we'll be back
after this short Nadya stop it what's up
louder with crowder mug club
Chael Sonnen here just want to wish you
all a very happy 4th of July
and it's a great time to think about
what you're proud of when it comes to
being American and I can tell you I am
very proud that our nation is the most
generous and compassionate nation in the
history of the human species we will
create things like vaccines and share
them with other countries including our
enemies pest resistant crops that could
have caused starvation
throughout many different continents but
we're happy to share that even our
military power well we could destroy any
other culture or country on the face of
the earth America does not has not and
will not because we have made any moral
obligation to help and to continue to
help and at the end that's really who we
are
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stop playing games with your personal
protection try the Walther today you see
what I did there with the stop playing
games
Baltar's happy about it let's all go to
the birdshot let's all go to the lair
buy ourselves some sweaty snazzy
clothing and swag divided louder with
crowded shop calm like this new
signature baseball team for these Ranger
panties and of course the Holy Grail
itself mug Club
[Music]
[Applause]
happy American culture is a product of
constant and radical cultural
appropriation we're a great country
because all these cultures get together
and they learn from each other they have
what's called ideas sex yeah and I'll
tell you what that makes that makes for
great innovations but also super good
food ever eat a burrito you get to take
rights from China that's where it
started or maybe India but who cares
then you take you take meat like cow
from the old world and then you take
tomatoes and peppers from the new world
you know like South America the Andes
wherever then you take cheese which they
say started in Turkey but don't tell the
Swiss that and don't tell the French
that either oh my god I don't to start a
cheese war either way put it all
together wrap it in a flour or corn
tortilla and you got yourself a Mexican
burrito
yummy yummy so hooray for a delicious
cultural appropriation I'm a food [ __ ]
put all your food my mom at the same
time hey it's moving day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where am I I've taken a vacation time in
the Bahamas oh no it's Mordor
I'm gonna take the ring to the Mount
Doom Oh No
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
for six three two one four six charlie
groups of eight point seven services for
free which is a three one one seven
eight eight eight two four six six seven
eight point seven six four five six what
I have
[Music]
shall I compare thee to a summers day
when I have the Rose which the disease
I don't love me shall I compare
days
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
louder with Crowder shopkins supporting
free speech since 2000 and something
with people being banned from social
media left and right you can now
purchase this D platform this
limited-edition louder with fetish
up.com t-shirt
signifying your in subordinates to
Authority and request for them to kiss
your ass and lick your long bladder with
parish up calm today happy 4th of July
louder with Crowder more clop here's the
most American thing I can think of me I
mean come on you looking at a guy who
immigrated from Holland to the United
States with his family to live the
American dream and I'm doing it listen
I'm even making a video right now for
one of the greatest shows in America too
bad I can't watch football because
that's pretty American right because
I've been holed up right now but guess
what I'm watching ladies soccer and
soccer is pronounced football I'll take
it happy 4th everybody god speeds and
party orders
[Music]
and we are back thank you bas Rutten n
Brian Jalen by the way let's bring up
the drinking rules here really quickly
so people can see everyone here is if
they still Rend right there you go you
take a drink every single time like we
said this is the last installment of a
live stream until August first yeah
we're going to have a long-form episodes
change my mind here next week follow me
on letters Crowder on Instagram a lot of
Carter listen I'm not gonna lie this is
a it's been oh join up love cutter that
come slash Michael if you want this
content to continue because you know LOX
wants us gone and so the Young Turks
have to we just cross four million they
know well by the time October we're
coming for you or me baby was I about to
mention anything else oh you know what
trivia trivia answer three three slaves
draymond Green and the Commissioner of
the NBA Oh
because they don't have owners anymore
yes but Laura games is a business owner
still before we get back to Pete but gig
who looks as though he just had warheads
a lemon sour warhead too cute Maddy has
some new mug club join up so let's see
these really some mud club join ups
there yes Oh fiery red thank you there
we go and that was a cigar that was the
answer just my club adolfo G thank you
so much your mug will not get there soon
because we are backordered so we're
sorry and what's this most of men most
American thing you can think of joining
thank you so much that's what keeps the
[ __ ] that's the only reason were able to
do this because if it gets removed you
can watch them the blaze and what else
we have a really quickly we have tea at
the costume contest will ring costume
contest winners for cultural
appropriation out of our runners-up all
right okay Donald Trump lesbian Donald
Trump on the last yes and then uncle
Uncle Sam Uncle Sam well yeah on the
right yes let's be nice no that's a
great that's a very patriotic outfit
very I don't know it's Uncle Sam or its
Apollo Creed after Dolph Lundgren killed
him
I will break okay if he dies he said
before that's the greatest and then okay
the winner we have the winner winner is
look at this crowd awesome the right to
bear grill my arms I see is very well
played all right we're gonna send you a
t-shirt over there the costume cultural
appropriation month alright bye red
let's see what he's very post he ran out
of the Pentagon this is a question from
our viewers we put some dude chillin out
behind them maybe they could share some
here's my I came from Kathleen's in a
whitey organ who writes many fear the
current administration has inflicted
irrevocable harm on our governing
institutions and norms and the process
on our reputation of brought the
question but what do you see as
important early steps in reversing the
damage done and we'll put this assumes
there's been damage right lemonade the
First Amendment at eighty five justices
a Supreme Court read reparations or
deliberation see at home at this point
Dahmer trumpeted is all for reparations
in the states that voted for him pretty
much you can believe in freedom of the
press hey Bay California paid Flores
sherry he believes in this now is that
Hickenlooper Bennett in DC we know
everything he said was a lie everything
he said was wrong have you not been
watching the debate have you yeah I'm
not a surprise but it's like come on he
doesn't believe in the rule of law
what's amazing to me is they just
they're picking the worst answers it's
like Rocky
it's like rocky book or like but mostly
picked the wrong hat yeah you know what
it is they confusing President Trump
with Donald Trump talking out of his ass
on Twitter
yes yeah and about Bill Clinton win the
rule of law how about that by the way
people who are list you do have to tune
in your television or another YouTube
tab to the end of these debates because
they will remove us if we run at full
screen so people are going like we can't
hear it that's because we can't play it
for you so you play a side by side this
is a watch along but you I don't want to
hear what they have to say another one
of those down the line and this is what
this question is which is you got
have to read you're likely gonna have to
reset a relationship between America and
and another country or entity if you
become president because entity Mary Ann
Williams and I had an encounter once
mention because the relationship we have
right now is too strong we need to dumb
it down to reset as president go down
the line and I'll start with Miss
Wayne's from either Hickenlooper or
Bennett I don't know which okay two
words Colorado move on to China we get
it we get it you legalize to lose no
genic mushrooms
let's move mister Colorado and China
think he'll be agents are succinct we
need to cooperate with him on climate
change AI another cooperate with the
beginning of climate change my idea
which our most important allies he will
have pissed off worse between now and
then what we know is that our
relationship would be we are
strengthened try to be quick because
yeah you're gonna you're gonna solve the
Middle East conflict as a gay mayor
Indiana and USS awesome why don't you
went to friends of the United Nations
thank you very much chocolate chip I
appreciate it give me some of that Chips
Ahoy
no have you not seen the legal bill we
have trying to fight box we have generic
Kroger cookies likely our European
allies in every latin-american country
that's willing to have a conversation
he does the congressman swallow his
mouth tonight you have made your decades
of that even close you know something I
was not expecting a good way to break
all right consequential foreign policy
decisions of the last century
you've oh she has the deepest voice out
there you have since said you regret
that vote of course he regrets it - no
yes - making a decision I was more
insurance until I got a pole shoes Bush
abused that power
what happened more like he got elected
after that I made sure the president
turned to me and said Joe get our combat
troops out of Iraq I was responsible for
getting 150,000 combat troops out of
Iraq and my son was one of them I also
generally when I send our troops into a
war on terror I like them to be combat
troops yes yes I understand you need
some medics and some chefs but if we
just send over if we were to only pull
back our combat troops we're kind of
hanging some IT guys out to dry yeah a
little bit probably gonna wind up in
case that one is just a guy up on a
telephone pole hello guys where'd you go
only be used for what it's intended what
what's intense voice is to go after
terrorists but never do it alone that's
what I have to repair as we put together
countries make sure we dealt with Isis
in Iraq and other places that's what I
would do I just thought you said you
wanted to pull all of our combat out and
I would send in Air Bud because there's
nothing in the rule books that say
golden retrievers can't go into combats
right baby
someone just sped up
everything I can to prevent a wheel with
the rod which would be far worse Oh
everything you can like watch giving
them everything they want until they
have a nuclear weapon letting them do
whatever the hell they want we got to
make a little bit more money all right
we have the most American thing the most
American thing the most from the gas or
we're waiting one woman okay we are
gonna have to go here really quickly to
uh the most American thing that you guys
can think of we had a montage of all the
people who submitted and answered and we
appreciate it this is this is real
here's the truth the reason people say
and they talk about how well they don't
give in to substantive policy
discussions regarding a foreign policy
you know why because they don't have
anything no no they were laughed at and
so what happened was they say well hon
second we believe that our our image has
been tarnished abroad and Donald Trump
has said mean things the truth is
they're they haven't offered anything
now I do appreciate that Bernie Sanders
talked about Yemen that is a but most
people just said I haven't heard that
phrase until Chandler thought he was
making it up to try and leave Janice
yeah really I'm going to Yemen we have
the most American I've done terrible
right now there we go that was random
montage the most American thing you can
think perfect
[Music]
believable
if we don't control insiders this will
be oh the most American thing is my
California mug my flag pins might hats
having the autograph of the 45th
President of the United States
sleeping under an American flag having
the Holy Bible the Constitution in the
hakka Constitution having the Ronald
Reagan autograph a flag wallet the
Capitol the Supreme Court the Statue of
Liberty and Saturn five having it tried
to place the national anthem now that's
the most American thing out well it was
it would be the most American thing out
there if you had the right mug yeah what
is that I don't know that's pretty good
come on get nothing
come on you know Talent mediocre music
no that's unbelievable what's that guy
is that guy one of those autograph Haga
CMZ yeah who got a seat big guy still
around he's far too young to have
procured an autograph from Ronald ray is
somebody got it you know for him yeah
you can get you can buy that oh he looks
like he stole it well Reagan jr. you
wasn't breaking soon you're here and run
run right I feel like Ronald Reagan jr.
is the kind of guy who would go out and
like make a bunch of money at comic-con
selling shining Reagan and just he just
wouldn't he wouldn't lie he just
wouldn't correct people right ate his
water right Junior yeah victim oh is
this are we coming back with Rachel
Maddow look look at this dead air that
they have you guys can't see this
there's like five seconds of blue of a
black screen they're making sure they
have the audio right okay all right here
we go here we go this is the finals
referee Holmes we're almost there guys
we're almost there
all right let's hear this we can't be a
forward-looking party if we look to the
Past for our leadership I don't know
what it could look like before but it
was dedicated work done
oh is that Man Thing
I went to Congress at 31 I found at
Washington that doesn't work and I've
Shuckle of the government's feet ever
since here we go here we go generation
of members of Congress and student debt
that's right drinks yes but you just
told them if they can to do anything
else all the generations by the way the
you can't pay for your own health care
that you can't pay for your own school
but you're gonna shake China's arm and
make sure if they follow here we go not
going to be beaten just by insider
politics talk he's not going to be
beaten just by someone takes an author
it takes a crazy it takes a crazy [ __ ]
is going to be beaten by voodoo you just
pull that a doll Donald Trump sticks a
pin in it I mean she literally has your
bull for major league right looking into
the wrong camera yeah this is a rabbit
shopping with you I am going to harness
love to rebuild their shattered I came
searching religious freedom here here I
nearly at risk in the United States
especially among children living in
poverty like the ones I used to work for
in the Denver Public Schools that's why
I'm running for president I've had a
tough races in Colorado by bringing
people together not by making empty
promises and I believe we need to build
a broad coalition of Americans
and the Trump that was that better
Gilbert that's great we've seen American
opera Kenzi this is going to be hard to
do but it's yes some would say for you
almost impossible thank you thank you
brought that same scrappy spirit to make
Colorado one of the most is pretty damn
purple yeah do they like their druthers
swinging back they want to keep their
gun down right exactly state to legalize
marijuana and we transformed our justice
system in the process handle the climate
change with the toughest methane
regulations in the country dude what is
up Keys methane economy in America wait
what you don't need they make you look
at the stance apart if we his mouth is
what you see on the packet of cigarettes
the warning Gillibrand you love this
person right you know it's almost like
consultants said you know I I like
Hillary Clinton but she's Tora thetic
she's not scripted enough and she's too
likable really amateur quickly to the
Pentagon and repealed Don't Ask Don't
Tell so that's how her modern banking
system was breaks out first of all is in
she was the Blue Dog Democrat she was
probably just standing outside of Bear
Stearns with a sign you guys are
[ __ ] you guys are dead
I'm gonna run for president I'll show
you Bernie Madoff it's like yeah and
your brother she was a Blue Dog Democrat
until like New York City Democrats said
you know you have to change your payer
and everything she okay our democracy
still works you're doing and that is who
can beat Donald Trump in 2029 yang's
defense he's a venom AWS allegedly all
that matters economy that is already
drawing thousands of disaffected Trump
voters conservatives disaffected voters
and libertarians as well as Democrats
and progressives I am that candidate I
can build a much broader coalition to
beat Donald Trump
it is not left it is not right it is it
is not left you want to give everybody a
thousand dollars for crying out loud
we did abandoned it that's his left as
he said that's too far left for us okay
okay all right come on who has the
ability to prosecute the case against
four more years
Donald prosecutor Oh prosecutor I
thought she was talking about all the
black she put in prison oh wow that's
about your hopes and your dreams
25% of Gerrits families yeah three
o'clock in the morning she also plays
used war agenda that is about everything
from what we need to hold school deliver
health care to how you will be able to
pay the go job yes I speak Joe country
what she's saying is give me your money
[Music]
as I go bumped in this to pop out okay
speaking the truth and giving the
America true they need to get through
the end of the month in a way that
giving what are you gonna get you're
gonna give your own money yeah exactly
your own money there
I'm going to reunite America like Biggie
and Tupac the way listened to in college
while puffing was like an experience of
writing a letter to my family putting it
in an envelope marked just in case what
else when you do whatever they would
know where to find it in case I didn't
come back from Afghanistan
okay Abed though has experience with I
do appreciate his service but it's not a
second letter guiding that I wrote you
put an envelope after watching
Philadelphia's just in case $20,000
when I took office our into a brighter
future a running because the decisions
we make a brighter future for mayor of
South Bend I wouldn't necessarily call
that light at the end good lord he's the
mayor of the city of South Bend
solutions Rachel there's a reason Notre
Dame made their own City right next to
you it would be a part of your stunting
the only person he could drag on stage
to make him seem qualified is Marianne
Williamson and maybe the understudy to
the mayor for Stockton how come nothing
really changes cuz you're at the last 45
years wages have been stagnant your
class by the way it's rate a middle
class poverty student that three people
we should all be we should hug what's
left Phillies up there I know we can't
do it again though that almost got my
heart blood all countries were you
saying blowed up that's literally just
everyone has to drink their whole mug
everything he just said much yeah the
rich what if the rich get richer and
said why but he's getting richer right
now burn exactly
everyone is getting richer Riley would
if anyone is a poor know I don't know
but we're going to leave this country
because I think it's important we
restore the soul of this nation this
president has ripped
that's the soul like for uncle mama it's
like a baby born alive Reverend
supremacist what white supremacist
honestly we just go as an extreme
because we needed to fill out the palate
thank you I'm empty from burgers from
the Bourbon I mean everything kinda
bourbon yet I really know clients I
really cover the bridge Stevens bourbon
fudge they're really getting it in there
says we can if we do there's not a
single thing the American people can't
do this is the United States of America
we can do anything if we're together
together well if you have the right
ideas to bring us together yeah but I
school and got no college do I make it
right yes that's all them that's it two
nights of debates two nights of met
ideas guys it's really Chuck Todd
there's women
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel maddow
okay so let me we're gonna we're gonna
take a break and come back with a full
recap after this but really quickly
nothing surprise me for tonight if you
look at the prep everything we had was
pretty much prepared one thing I will
say though is you know when people say
Republicans are the party of the rich
they say that but II need to look at the
rhetoric coming of the Republican Party
coming out of Donald Trump the rhetoric
assumes something okay that doesn't
matter because it tells you what they
believe to be the American ideal and it
also tells you what they believe to be
their voting base ideal it assumes
Donald Trump assumes that people believe
in themselves it assumes that America is
successful that people understand this
is the most successful nation in the
world right now tonight
they couldn't even pivot they had to act
as though the middle class is shrinking
they had to act as though unemployment
is at record high they had to act as
though the economy isn't working they
had to act as though we weren't safer
than we were before they have to act as
though everyone out there is downtrodden
incapable and helpless why because they
require that of you to be elected
Democrats can only be elected if your
life sucks when people's lives are going
well when the American Dream or
certainly when people feel at least and
believe that the American Dream is alive
and well Republicans tend to win when
they think that they need a leg up they
vote for Democrats right now we have a
rip-roaring economy that's the best that
our generation has ever seen and it
amazed me because I thought well maybe
they'll have to come in and sort of
explain it away right so we have some
prep here for them trying to explain in
a way you know saying that Americans are
working for jobs which also wasn't true
so I had some of these talking points
that I assumed they would use to try and
address the economic prosperity that
we're facing instead they just said the
economy sucks
they just said right everybody's Laden
is terrible right now and I think that
that is going to come across as really
tone-deaf with most Americans but let me
know what you think comment below I'm so
grateful that it has not been removed
tonight G Morgan Jr's quarterblack
Garrett thank you so much my wonderful
friend and writer Brautigan we are going
to be gone until August first but we're
going to have masterclass installments
and change my mind uploading here
through July we'll come back into a
little new studio courtesy of you guys
joining up a lot of chatter calm / mug
Club anyway so much appreciate it we
cannot continue the show without you and
you know what um we love you
we're gonna take a quick break and stay
with us because we're going to recap
what happened tonight you know what I
feel I feel that my words I think they
might be best put into a song yes what
will be back my name is dotan April and
I'm the creator of earthworm jim I love
God and I love my country and the most
American thing I could think of doing is
chewing Copenhagen and backing my book
Earthworm Jim on IndieGoGo are you ready
kids
[Music]
be sure not to tell your dad what I did
[Music]
[Music]
happy fourth fellow latter with crowd
our muggers folks my favorite thing
about American culture is we're the only
country in the world that counts chasing
the American dream as exercise where you
can go to the same building for a big
gulp and a dialysis machine i'm
razörfist god is speed Auto way
[Music]
Bernie Sanders
but in in game
[Music]
also peed but gay who kept his main name
[Music]
Hickenlooper
[Music]
whoever that guy is
not super familiar but I'm sure that
he's afraid
Wow [ __ ]
[Music]
everything they'll say
Wow Wow [ __ ] up your horseshit to
fame
[Music]
[Applause]
cried out impeachment
[Music]
it drove us to drain
[Music]
Michael Ben
[Applause]
no one cares what she found
you want all our freedom
you still cheap and line
[Music]
still Thane Peabody
has a mean case of pinkeye
Wow [ __ ] everything you see Wow Wow [ __ ]
your shadow
[Applause]
Wow [ __ ] everything you say
[Applause]
Wow
[Music]
thank you everybody happy for its next
week is master class and then we'll be
back first live stream August 1st thanks
so much have a good one product in
Strunk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
somewhere
[Music]
the
[Music]